Yesterday, the Supreme Court denied Donald Trump's
absolute final last remaining attempt to cancel
out his election loss in Wisconsin. The Supreme
Court order was unsigned with no noted dissent,
simply saying justices are declining to take
to declining to take up Donald Trump's lawsuit.
This is the lawsuit in which Donald Trump
claims Wisconsin's election officials violated
the Constitution by letting more people vote
absentee due to the pandemic. Remember that
Joe Biden won Wisconsin by about 20000 votes.
Donald Trump sued over those results about a month
after the 2020 election. This is now if you are
keeping track, more than 60 total losses and one
narrow win, which did nothing for Trump in terms
of the election when Trump went to court over
the election. Now, just because they rejected the
case doesn't mean that nobody at the Supreme Court
wanted to hear the case. The court's denial of
Trump's appeal yesterday means that fewer than
four justices agreed to hear the case. It's
conceivable that one, two or three of them did
actually want to take this case. And recently,
a few of the more right wing justices suggested
they might actually be interested in looking at
issues relating to what the Constitution says
about the authority that states have to decide
how to run an election, including things like
expanding absentee ballots during a pandemic. To
everyone who wants one here, we don't know if zero
one, two or three justices wanted to hear the
case, only that not enough wanted to hear it,
and thus they will not be hearing
the case now. I should also mention,
and this is this is really a bigger story about
the psyche of the American right at this point
in time. Even if the Supreme Court decided
to take this case, it's all pointless. It's
an it's pointless for a few reasons. Number one,
it's not clear that you can nullify an election
after the electoral votes have been certified
and counted and the next president is in office.
Even if somehow the Supreme Court had taken this
case and the Supreme Court decided Wisconsin
should not have expanded absentee voting. And
somehow that led to so give Wisconsin to Trump,
which also is no foregone conclusion. Even if the
case were taken up by the court and they decided
the absentee ballots shouldn't have been expanded,
that doesn't even mean Trump gets the state.
But even if Trump did get the state, it still
doesn't give Donald Trump enough electoral votes
to get to 270. And so it's all pointless. But
this is this is officially the last remaining
loose end. And as I was reading about this
this morning, my takeaway is, you know,
as we learned as we approached March 4th, when
there were many people who thought Trump is
going to get re inaugurated on March 4th, the day
came and went. And of course, it didn't happen.
There are a significant number of people in
this country who believe as an ongoing matter,
that it's plausible that once the
term of a new president has started,
that courts might just say they're out. Previous
guy goes in and the previous president would just
be reinstated because of some kind of overlooked
mistake somewhere in there where all people in
Wisconsin shouldn't have been allowed to vote
absentee for any reason, like the idea of being
the president is it's just some guy and they could
be replaced at any time. And it would just be kind
of like no big deal. Trump someone would just say
John Roberts would bang a gavel. I don't know if
the Supreme Court has gavels at this point, would
bang a figurative gavel, a proverbial gavel, and
Biden's escorted out and Trump is escorted back
in. Like the idea that that's even a possibility
shows you how either ignorant or deeply committed
to these delusions so many people are. And part
of the reason why is that right wing media for
the last four months has essentially been based
on the idea, even if they don't say it when. Fox
News, Newsmax own Rush Limbaugh, while while he
was still doing his show in the live, etc.,
that they run on the idea all the time,
that the reason for their principled conservatism
is that tradition is super sacred. Things can't be
modified, history, precedent, tradition, norms.
But in this case, it's like if Amy CONI Barrett
decides they're going to do it, they pull
Biden out two months into his term and say
somebody else is going to replace him. And it
really shouldn't be that surprising because
these are the same people, even the ones that
didn't participate in the January 6th riots.
Many believed that storming the Capitol with
whatever violence they deem to be necessary
could theoretically prevent Joe Biden from
becoming president. It's the same ideology
if you think that maybe March 4th, Biden gets
yanked out or maybe the Supreme Court in March
or April or May decides Biden out Trump. And if
you believe that's possible, you're probably the
same type of person who believes we might be able
to physically do something in Washington, D.C. on
the 6th that will give Donald Trump a second term.
And many of them, their ignorance was weaponized
by the fact that they were able to be convinced of
that. And that's that. This is really the bigger
principle of modern American conservatism. It's
the old idea of conservatism. We must maintain
traditional values and ideas and procedures
and resist change for the in groups. Right.
But if all of a sudden those values and protocols
and traditions protect or bolster some outgroup,
be it Democrats or minorities or whoever else,
then the principles go in the trash. And something
like a violent uprising on January 6th to prevent
Biden from being president despite winning,
seems like a reasonable and acceptable thing
to do. That's modern conservatism, and it is
based in the hypocrisy we've seen from
the Republican Party for a long time